I've lost so many friends seen so much
chance enjoy being the first people on
the planet to drink sometimes I wonder
why fate chose me to live when they all
died oh yeah cuz I'm not a dumbass haha
my name's Floyd I was a head scientist
at Fisk Oh but I decided to leave
because her health insurance doesn't
cover this they ain't just given me a
bit more time to research overcharge I'm
sure I would have figured out it would
do this or that and I definitely
probably would have caught but if you
think their accidents are nasty wait
till you see what they're making on
purpose they've got eyes everywhere and
now they send in a legion of bots to
quote liquidate their assets fish go
cover up begin and I must say they are
efficient workers it's our turn go ahead
and check the exceeds expectations box
on their year-end assassination review
oh damn and there's little o you in the
center of all this but you seem to be
holding your own and ever since I
crossed your path survival has gotten a
lot more survivable but don't get cocky
stay moving in today's shooting if you
stand around you're gonna die and then
I'm gonna die and then I want to put my
ghostly foot up yo go sleep
go forth and enjoy your apocalypse have
fun